Catherine you are drenched in the
this moment you what was that like uh
well I made them promise me that I
wouldn't be cold blood that it would be
warm and of course they lied and said it
would be warm blood it was terribly cold
that's blood is blood and it's always
fun so ease who else gets to do that
really and just get drenched in blood
mark kill people and it was just fun it
was really like a laugh the whole time
it's a very unusual script isn't it what
did you guys both think when you first
read it mmm
well you know the script was sent to me
and as I was reading it I was trying to
do decide for myself is this a thriller
is this a horror film is this and what's
interesting about it and the way they
make the film is that it's all those
things together so I'm I find it a very
exciting film because it actually it
touches a lot of different territories
and manages to then them well together
okay yeah I feel the same it was just um
it was so new and interesting something
that I hadn't I hadn't seen before and
or read before just the strong female
independent character who goes through
the ups and the downs and you really see
the light sigh in the dark side of her
but as she sort of explores this world
that she has no idea about the things
happen to her just felt it was something
I had never seen before and I would like
to watch so of course I'd want to be a
part of it if I wanted to watch it he
touched on a little bit of it there but
can you expand maybe on how you think
your character and America marry the
title character does stand out from the
other women in horror films well I think
there's there's definitely a tendency
for women horror films to be victims and
Mary you know she was a bit of a victim
and then overcame that became you know
the victor in ways and at the same time
she was still sort of a tragic figure
and I don't think that's represented a
lot I think people are generally
uncomfortable with watching women be the
aggressor or it's sort of a taboo
subject no one you know they want all
the women to be nice and pretty and a
nice little pretty box and just you know
be nice happy lovely women and and I
think this blows that out of the water
so that was interesting and what's it
like being in such a kind of female
movie a female star is very different
kind of horror female lead and also
directed by Chen and Sylvia's Oscar two
female directors it's fantastic I mean
working with all these people was really
wonderful and you know the twins
themselves are very confident directors
but also very easy collaborators as is
Catherine you know and I think in a way
it's it's really not surprising at all
to me that these three found each other
to create this film because they've all
got that sense of ease and confidence
you know Catherine I knew you grew up on
film sets I mean even before she was
acting I think you told me that your
parents were involved
my parents are filming and you know the
twins feel like filmmakers that have
been doing this for 20 years
they've got they've got quite a sense of
open collaborative spirit behind their
work and I I've said this before I think
it's the fact that they work together as
collaborators just as their business
model I mean they write together and
they direct together so they were
wonderful to work with Catherine how did
you find it I mean how did they kind of
split up their duties on sand I'm
calling it there they both wrote it you
can sometimes tell who wrote what scenes
and who wrote what other scenes but they
are very collaborative and they're so
enthusiastic and they hug everybody and
they're so positive
it made the entire filmmaking experience
happy for everybody every single crew
member was stoked to be there and felt
really important really good at their
job and I think that's what they're
really great at as well as as you know
they split up their duties so he was
saying is very emotionally attached to
Mary so sometimes it would get a little
overwhelming her in general you sit
there and you just have a little have a
little tear for for Mary and well take
care of everything else here Jen sort of
allows Silve to make everything happen
she gets everything done so it's
possible and are you guys normally
horror fans her we are her but it's
myself I'm a bit of a chicken so I am
aware of every time I yeah I get scared
easily yeah oddly some of yeah
absolutely yeah I mean I I've been a
horror fan for a long time and it's
funny I don't remember us talking about
this as a horror film where is being
made I don't think what I don't think it
is yeah it's got it's got different
elements added to it so I get I guess
I'm a fan of really good storytelling
and that was the thing right from the
first time I read this this script I
thought I would love to be a part of
this film
you